so we have this circle call it circle Oh
based on the point at its center and we
have the segment OD and we're told that
segment OD is a radius of circle Oh fair
enough
we're also told that segment OD is
perpendicular to this chord to chord AC
or to segment AC and what we want to
prove is that segment OD bisects AC so
another way to think about it it
intersects AC at a C's midpoint so pause
this video and see if you can have a go
with that alright now let's go through
this together and the way that I'm going
to do this is by establishing two
congruent triangles and let me draw
these triangles so I'm going to draw one
radius going from o to C and another
from a to O now we know that the length
a o is equal to OC because because a o
and O see both radii in a circle
the length of the radius does not change
so I can put that right over there and
then we also know that om is going to be
congruent to itself it's a side in both
of these triangles so let me just write
it this way
Oh M is going to be congruent to om and
this is reflexivity reflexivity kind of
obvious it's going to be equal to itself
it's going to be congruent to itself so
you have it just like that and now we
have two right triangles how do I know
they're right triangles well they told
us that segment OD is perpendicular to
segment AC and our assumptions in our
given now if you just had two triangles
that had two pairs of congruent sides
that is not enough to establish
congruence of the triangles but if
you're dealing with two right triangles
then it is enough and there's two ways
to think about it we had thought about
the
our s.h postulate or if you have a right
triangle and or two right triangles you
have a pair of sides are congruent a
pair and the hypotenuse is are congruent
that means that the two triangles are
congruent but another way to think about
it which is a little bit of common sense
is using the Pythagorean theorem if you
know two sides of a right triangle the
Pythagorean theorem would tell us that
you could determine what the other side
is and so what we could say is and let's
just use our SH for now but you could
also say we can use the Pythagorean
theorem to establish that a M is going
to be congruent to M C but let me just
write it this way I will write that
triangle a M o is congruent to triangle
C M o by r sh and if the triangles are
congruent then the corresponding sides
must be congruent so therefore we know
that am a M segment am is going to be
I'm having trouble Rankin cruet is going
to be congruent to segment C M that
these are going to have the same measure
and if they have the same measure we
have just shown that M is the midpoint
of AC or that OD bisects AC so let me
just write it that way therefore oh d
bisects a C segment a OD bisects segment
AC and we're done